>> All right Charles, what do you think?
>> I don't know but I know how to do it.
>> All right.
>> I'm just going to substitute any equation we had before.
>> Yeah, that's what I was thinking, uh-huh.
>> Alright, so M is greater than or equal to, 1 over
epsilon times the natural log of the size of the hypothesis space.
>> Mm, which is what, that is not one of our variables here.
>> ten.
>> Yeah. Right, so it's not 2 to the 10. Even though
the input space is 2 to the 10. The number of hypotheses.
There's one hypothesis corresponding to each of the bit positions. So, good?
>> Right. Plus, the natural log of 1 over delta. So
that would be greater than or equal to ten times the natural log of ten.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Plus the natural log of, five. So,
let's see. The natural log of ten is something
like three point something, the natural log of five is something like, two point
something. We add those up, multiply by ten you're going to end up with 39.12.
>> Good, so, we need, you know, 40 samples?
>> Yeah. That sounds about right.
>> That actually doesn't sound too bad. Well, you
know, it's not learning a very hard problem, but
it's, you know, a pretty big input space. So
let's see. What, how big is the input space?
It's like two to the ten, which is.
>> 1,024.
>> 1,024. So how much of 1024 is 40? It's,
it's, you know, less than 4%. Hm, that's not bad.
>> Before we leave this quiz, let me point out one
more thing: that this bound is actually agnostic to the distribution
from which samples came, so this idea that it's from a
uniform distribution is actually not being directly used here. So so
this is pretty cool. It actually doesn't matter, we only
need 40 samples no matter what the distribution is. It's
not like some distributions are harder or easier ,because we
are measuring the true error on the same distribution that we
used to, to create the training set. So if it's
a really hard distribution and some tough examples never appear,
then we're unlikely to see them in the training set,
but they're not going to contribute very much to the true error.
>> Well that makes sense. So the
distri, oh right. So in some sense, I
mean, I guess the equation doesn't show this,
but in some sense, the distribution is, cancels
out between the training and the true error
>> Yeah, that's one way to think about it.
>> Well, I like that. So 40 is pretty good to get 10% error.
If we wanted to get say, only 1% error, Then we would go from 40 to 400.
>> Mm.
>> Right?
>> That's a good
point, yeah.
>> And it's, it's, it's one decimal point even.
And so, that would be about 40% of the data.
>> Yeah, that's true. Yeah, if we want to go a little
bit beyond that we may need all the data multiple times.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Yeah, but this example doesn't look so bad. So
let's just move on before we think about it too hard.
>> Okay. That seems fair, I like that.